y todo lo que hemos estado tratando en
este viaje a través de la química ha
girado en torno a la estabilidad de los
electrones y además que los electrones
prefieren estar en órbitas estables y
como todas las cosas en la vida si tú
exploras un poco más profundo en la idea
del átomo te darás cuenta que los
electrones no son lo único que está
pasando en el átomo
el núcleo por sí mismo tiene
interacciones o tiene algo de
inestabilidad que necesita ser revelado
de alguna manera y justo de esto
hablaremos un poco en este vídeo y bueno
actualmente esto se da en la mecánica
del primer curso anual de química que
están muy por fuera del alcance pero
pese a ello es muy bueno al menos
conocer que estas cosas ocurren y bueno
espero que un día estudiemos la
interacción nuclear fuerte así como la
física cuántica y todo alrededor de ello
para así platicar como es que los
electrones y los protones
y los quarks están interactuando de la
forma en la que lo hacen pero bueno por
ahora pensemos en las diferentes maneras
en las que el núcleo puede pues
esencialmente decaer así que para ello
imagínate que tenemos aquí un montón de
protones dibujemos aquí a mis protones
tengo 12
4 5 6
7 protones ok deja no poner algunos
neutrones y para eso voy a utilizar un
color neutral voy a utilizar este este
color gris que me parece un color
neutral y voy a dibujar 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y
8 y voy a dibujar por a 4 + 9 neutrones
y bueno así que digamos que este es el
núcleo de nuestro átomo y bueno
recordemos que en el primerísimo vídeo
que hice sobre los átomos te contaba que
el núcleo si lo quisiéramos dibujada por
aquí junto con el átomo actual bueno
pues es muy difícil de dibujar un átomo
porque no tiene fronteras bien definidas
los electrones pueden estar en algún
momento dado ya sabes en cualquier duda
algo más o menos así así
así pero bueno si tú dices ok existe un
90% del tiempo en el cual los electrones
van a estar
esta frontera que estoy dibujando justo
aquí en esta circunstancia supongamos
que es una circunferencia es decir en la
circunferencia de nuestro átomo bueno
como ya vimos en el primer vídeo el
núcleo es siempre una porción
infinitesimal del volumen de esta esfera
en donde se encuentran los electrones el
90% del tiempo y es más déjenme ponerlo
con este mismo color y esta pequeñísima
parte sería nuestro núcleo y esto nos da
pie a decir que realmente todo lo que
vemos en la vida es vacío toda esta
parte es simplemente vacío pero bueno
realmente quiero repetir esto porque el
sitio infinitesimal del cual estamos
hablando el cual es una pequeña muy
pequeña parte del volumen total del
átomo y la cual curiosamente tiene casi
toda la masa del átomo es esta pequeña
parte de la cual estoy haciendo un
acercamiento justo acá arriba estos no
son átomos esos no son electrones esto
de aquí es una
ampliación del núcleo y bueno todo esto
lo hago porque quiero contarte que el
núcleo a veces es un poco inestable y
éste quiere llegar a tener una
configuración un poco más estable
nosotros no vamos a entrar en la
mecánica de definir exactamente qué es
un núcleo estable o inestable y todo lo
demás pero con el fin de entrar en un
núcleo un poco más estable
algunas veces éste emite una particular
la cual llamaremos el decaimiento alta y
déjenme escribirlo aquí la radiación
alta o el decaimiento de cara y viento
tipo alfa tipo alfa
alfa ok la cual por cierto emite una
partícula alfa las partículas baja
y la alfa y bueno tal vez esto suene un
poco fantástico pero lo que va a pasar
es que esta partícula alta es una
colección de neutrones y protones así
que esta partícula alfa de hecho son dos
protones y dos neutrones y bueno tal vez
estos tipos no se sienten como si
hubieran de encajar justo aquí y
entonces esta colección que tenemos aquí
déjame tomarme dos neutrones y dos
protones estos de aquí se van a emitir
del núcleo así que se van del núcleo así
que pensemos un poco qué le pasa al
átomo cuando pasa algo como esto por lo
tanto vamos a escribirlo aquí imagínate
que yo me tomo un elemento cualquiera el
cual le voy a poner el nombre del
elemento ok si te das cuenta este
elemento tiene protones y déjame ponerlo
con el color de los protones tiene
protones aquí tenemos el número atómico
y por otra parte tenemos una masa
atómica la cual es la cantidad de
protones más neutrales así que lo voy a
poner como p
más en la cantidad de protones más la
cantidad de neutrones y este es mi color
de neutrón ok ahora vamos a pensar qué
es lo que pasa con este elemento cuando
tiene un decaimiento tipo alfa que es lo
que va a pasar bueno pues lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que los protones
están decreciendo en dos se van a ir dos
protones y por lo tanto tenemos ahora un
número atómico de p menos 2 am lo voy a
poner así p - 2 y bueno date cuenta que
sus neutrones también van a disminuir en
todos por lo tanto vamos a tener am y se
ahora pensamos en el número de masa
atómica vamos a tener p ok
a esto le vamos a sumar en el ok pero
vamos a disminuir en 4 porque date
cuenta que se van a ir dos protones y
dos neutrones estamos disminuyendo en
cuatro el número de masa atómica y si te
das cuenta este ya es otro nuevo
elemento recuerda que los elementos
están definidos según el número de
protones que
así que en este decaimiento alfa cuando
estás perdiendo dos neutrones y dos
protones y especialmente estos dos
protones nos están dando un nuevo
elemento el cual voy a llamar y déjame
ponerlo así el elemento 2 si este era mi
elemento 1 ahora vamos a obtener un
elemento 2 ok
un nuevo elemento 2 ahora bien si tú
piensas un poco en qué es lo que estamos
generando a esto le vamos a aumentar
algo que tiene dos protones y déjenme
ponerlo con el color de los protones
algo que tiene dos protones y tiene una
masa atómica de cuatro tiene una masa
atómica de cuatro y bueno quiero que
veas con mucho ojo esto que son dos
protones y dos neutrones y bueno de
hecho no tengo la tabla periódica aquí
olvide pegarla antes pero no te será
difícil encontrar en la tabla periódica
un elemento con dos protones y dos
neutrones si lo piensas un poco
es el ello entonces realmente estamos
generando y déjame ponerlo con este
color de aquí una partícula de helio una
partícula de helio el cual por ende
tiene una masa atómica de 4 y tenemos un
núcleo de helio un núcleo atómico que se
emite del decaimiento tipo alfa ahora lo
que quiero que te des cuenta es que
tenemos un núcleo de helio de este
decaimiento tipo alfa sale un núcleo de
helio pero date cuenta que no tenemos
sus respectivos electrones para
equilibrar estos dos protones que hemos
emitido por eso podemos decir que es un
guión de helio es decir aquí tenemos
solamente dos protones o dicho de otra
manera tenemos nada de electrones y
entonces una carga positiva de dos así
que la partícula alfa realmente es un
guión de helio con carga 2 positiva este
ión que salió de un espontáneo
decaimiento del núcleo de otro átomo que
busca tener un
más estable pero bueno este es un tipo
de decaimiento
ahora vamos a explicar otro tipo de
decaimiento y para eso antes que no por
esto que tengo aquí vamos a borrar esto
que tengo aquí ok y vamos a trabajar con
el nuevo tipo de decaimiento y ahora
dibujemos otro núcleo atómico por aquí
voy a tomar este ecuador y vamos a hacer
algunos protones por aquí y apagamos a
algunos protones por aquí y también voy
a hacer algunos neutrones con este color
hagamos algunos neutrones por aquí este
este este este este este otro por aquí y
este otro por aquí este otro por aquí
este otro por aquí y bueno y bueno lo
que va a pasar es que a veces los
neutrones no se sienten confortables
consigo mismos se quedan viendo a lo que
hacen los protones diariamente y dicen
ah sabes una cosa por alguna razón
cuando miro hacia adentro de mí siento
como si realmente me gustaría ser
y si fuera un protón entonces el núcleo
estaría mucho más estable y bueno
entonces lo que hace este neutrón es
convertirse en protón para eso déjenme
agarrar este color y vamos a convertirlo
en protón
ahora bien recuerda un neutrón tiene
carga neutra y entonces lo que hace es
emitir un electrón y ya sé que estás
pensando sal en verdad esto suena muy
loco nosotros sabemos que los neutrones
no tienen electrones en ellos y de hecho
estoy de acuerdo contigo esto suena muy
loco y algún día estudiaremos todo lo
que sucede adentro del núcleo pero bueno
por ahora vamos a decir que puede emitir
un electrón así que vamos a decir que
emite
un electrón y bueno lo podemos
simplificar diciendo que tiene una masa
de 0 y no es que un electrón tenga una
masa de 0 pero si hablamos de unidades
de masa atómica el protón tiene una masa
de 1 mientras que el electrón tiene una
masa muy pequeña tiene una masa de 1
entre 1836 así que lo podemos redondear
y decir que su masa es cero
su masa no es cero pero es muy cercana a
cero y bueno su carga es menos 1 su
carga es menos 1 por lo tanto podemos
decir que su carga atómica es menos 1 y
que emitimos un electrón y al decir
emitimos un electrón su carga pasa de
ser neutral a ser positiva lo que hace
que se convierta el protón ya esto se le
conoce como el decaimiento tipo beta la
radiación beta o el decaimiento tipo
beta y lo voy a poner aquí el
decaimiento
y miento ok tipo beta tipo beta beta ok
una partícula beta realmente lo que hace
es emitir un electrón así que regresemos
a ver qué es lo que pasa con nuestro
caso del elemento en and tomémonos aquí
de nuevo a este elemento en que si tú
recuerdas éste tenía p protones and
déjame ponerlo así tiene protones y una
masa atómica de p más n p más n más el
número de neutrones ahora qué va a pasar
después del decaimiento tipo b está
bueno los protones cambiaron si los
protones aumentaron en 1 por lo tanto
ahora tenemos una cantidad de protones
de p
1 y qué pasó con la masa atómica cambio
bueno pues lo podemos ver así los
neutrones han disminuido en 1 pero los
protones han aumentado en 1 por lo tanto
su número de masa atómica no ha cambiado
sigue siendo p más
n p más
en el ojo su masa atómica sigue siendo
la misma como no era el caso del
decaimiento alta pero ahora el elemento
de nuevo cambio tenemos un protón de más
y por lo tanto esto ya no es el mismo
elemento ahora tenemos un nuevo elemento
2 así que déjame ponerlo así como espera
este es el elemento 1 ok y aquí tenemos
el elemento
2 un nuevo elemento del decaimiento tipo
beta recuerda la cantidad de protones
aumenta en 1 la cantidad de neutrones
disminuye en 1 y bueno pues estos dos se
van ahora pensemos qué pasa en otra
situación en la situación en que uno de
estos protones mira lo que hacen los
neutrones y dice sabes que yo veo cómo
viven es muy atractivo para mí y siento
que encajo mejor como un neutrón en esta
vida y bueno de hecho la comunidad de
partículas del núcleo atómico sería
mejor si yo fuera un neutrón así que
todo estaría
en una condición mucho más estable y
bueno qué va a pasar con este protón
incómodo vamos a decir que es este de
aquí este de aquí es mi protón incómodo
bueno pues tiene una cierta probabilidad
de emitir y sé que esta es una nueva
idea para ti este va a emitir un
positrón ojo que no es lo mismo que
protón éste emite un positrón un
positrón o sí
ok y que es un positrón bueno pues es
algo que tiene exactamente la misma masa
que un electrón es decir su masa es un
1.183 avon la masa de un protón y bueno
vamos a ponerle aquí un cero porque
recuerda que esto en unidades de masa
atómica es casi cero es decir es una
pequeña pero muy pequeña partícula pero
ahora a diferencia tiene una carga
positiva tiene una masa de cero una
carga positiva y bueno tal vez es un
poco confuso para ti pues escribo una en
una con un 1 por aquí y seguramente cada
vez que te encuentras con una m piensas
en un electrón pero le estoy poniendo
una e porque es un tipo de partícula muy
parecida pero en lugar de tener una
carga negativa tendrá una carga positiva
y este de aquí es un positivo y bueno ya
sé que tenemos algunos nombres muy
exóticos para nuestras partículas pero
esto es lo que realmente
si tú tienes un protón que emite uno de
estos tipos de partículas un post con la
cual tiene casi toda esta carga positiva
que estaba en ella entonces este protón
va a cambiar a ser un neutro en este
protón se va a convertir ahora en un
neutrón y justo a esto es a lo que le
llamamos la emisión de un positrón y
ahora veamos qué es lo que pasa con este
elemento si nosotros empezamos de nuevo
con nuestro elemento m
lo voy a poner aquí ok el cual recuerda
que tenía protones y la misma masa
atómica así que vamos a ponerlo tiene
pep protones y la misma masa atómica que
da p
n ok ahora qué va a pasar después de
pensar en esta emisión de positrón qué
va a pasar con nuestro nuevo elemento
bueno pues lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que este nuevo elemento tiene
un protón de menos por lo tanto este es
un elemento distinto ahora vamos a tener
p - un protón es p menos un protón es ok
pero qué es lo que va a pasar con
nuestra masa atómica si tú te das cuenta
nuestra masa atómica se mantiene igual
perdemos un protón pero ganamos un
neutrón por lo tanto tenemos una masa
atómica de p + n
y bueno date cuenta que tenemos un
elemento distinto no es así cuando
tenemos el decaimiento tipo beta
aumentamos en el número de protones
entonces nos movemos hacia la derecha en
la tabla periódica pero cuando tenemos
una emisión de positrón entonces
disminuimos el número de protones y eso
debería escribirlo
cuando tenemos una emisión de este
posición entonces lo voy a poner así a
este le vamos a aumentar un positrón lo
cual es algo que tiene una masa cercana
a cero una carga positiva ok y cuando
nosotros tenemos el decaimiento tipo
beta a esto am le voy a agregar un
electrón que es algo cercano a una masa
de 0 ok con una carga negativa y lo voy
a poner así se escriben de la misma
manera pero la diferencia es un menos
por aquí este menos por aquí y éste no
tiene ese menos este es el electrón
porque tiene una carga negativa mientras
que este es el positrón que tiene carga
positiva pero bueno hay una última forma
de decaimiento de la que sería bueno
hablar pero ésta no cambia el número de
neutrones o de protones en el núcleo sin
embargo ésta libera un montón de energía
y algunas veces libera un protón de alta
energía ya esto se le conoce como rayos
gamma hola
acción tipo gamma el decaimiento tipo
gamma y la radiación gamma significa que
estos tipos se reconfiguran a sí mismos
tal vez se acercan entre ellos a algo
más o menos así estos dos se acercan y
esto lo que hace es que se libere mucha
energía se libera energía en forma de
ondas electromagnéticas de alta
frecuencia lo cual esencialmente lo
podemos llamar la partícula gamma o el
rayo gamma y esto nos da un nivel de
energía muy alto y es justo por eso que
estoy seguro que no te gustaría estar
cerca de estos rayos gamma este tipo de
energía podría inclusive matarte pero
bueno qué te parece si hacemos algunos
problemas que tengan que ver con todo lo
que hemos aprendido hasta ahorita y
vamos a intentar averiguar de qué tipo
de decaimiento se trata así que déjame
borrar un poco esta pantalla que tenemos
aquí y voy a traer por acá a nuestros
ejercicios
y déjame bajar un poco en la pantalla
bajemos un poco la pantalla y ahora
tengo estos problemas por aquí bueno en
primer lugar aquí tengo al berilio al pp
cuya masa atómica es de 7 ok y lo voy a
convertir en litio con una masa atómica
también de 7 entonces qué ha pasado aquí
de mi ver y lyon se conserva la misma
masa atómica pero ahora voy a pasar de 4
protones a tener 3 protones así que
estoy reduciendo mi número de protones
mm hasta total no ha cambiado por lo
tanto en definitiva no es un decaimiento
tipo alfa recuerda que el decaimiento
tipo alfa libera del núcleo una
partícula de helio y bueno entonces qué
pasa aquí que estoy liberando date
cuenta que estoy liberando una carga
positiva o dicho de otra manera
estoy liberando un positrón y de hecho
lo puedes ver en esta ecuación esta
parte de aquí es un positrón
es un positrón ok así que este tipo de
decaimiento en donde pasamos de 7
perillo a 7 litio es una emisión de
positrón una emisión de positrón
bastante bien ahora veamos el siguiente
vamos a pasar de uranio 238 y este va a
decaer a torio 234 y aquí te puedes dar
cuenta que la masa atómica está
disminuyendo en cuatro unidades ok
mientras que el número de protones
también disminuye en este caso en dos
unidades así que date cuenta que estamos
liberando algo que tiene una masa
atómica de cuatro y tiene dos protones o
dicho de otra manera estamos liberando
un
estamos liberando un ello o lo que
podemos llamar partícula alfa ésta es la
partícula particular para ti
con la alfa y por lo tanto estamos
hablando del decaimiento tipo alta ahora
seguramente puedes decir no sal espera
algo raro está pasando aquí porque si
estoy disminuyendo el número de protones
de 90 a 92 es decir en dos entonces
debería de seguirte en dos mil 92
electrones justo aquí eso no quiere
decir entonces que me estoy quedando con
una carga de menos 2 justo aquí y mucho
más este el yo que estoy liberando no
tiene electrones en él es decir es solo
el núcleo del helio por lo tanto esta
partícula de aquí no tiene una carga
positiva de 2 y si tú piensas eso estás
absolutamente en lo correcto pero la
realidad es que justo cuando este
decaimiento pasa este torio no tiene
ninguna razón de retener esos dos
electrones así que esos dos electrones
desaparecen y el torneo se convierte en
neutro otra vez
este el yo de igual manera muy
rápidamente como necesitados electrones
para hacer estable los agarra de
cualquier lugar en donde se encuentren y
con ello se vuelve estable de nuevo y
bueno así lo puedes ver hagamos otro más
aquí tengo yo 231 ok y veamos qué pasa
mi masa no está cambiando es exactamente
la misma por lo tanto podemos pensar que
estamos pasando de protones neutrones o
de neutrones y protones pero aquí
podemos ver que tenemos 53 protones ok y
vamos a pasar a 54 o espera aquí me
falta un 4 54 es lo que dicen mis notas
ok estamos pasando del 53 54 protones
por lo tanto estamos en el caso en el
que un neutrón va a pasar a ser protón y
la forma en la que un neutrón se
transforme en un protón es emitiendo un
electrón estamos emitiendo un electrón y
lo podemos ver justo en el este
acción hemos emitido un electrón y
entonces estamos hablando de una
partícula beta ésta es una partícula
beta o podremos decir que en general
este decaimiento es el decaimiento
decaimiento tipo beta de que hay viento
ok
tipo beta y bueno de igual manera puedes
pensar que estamos aumentando el número
de protones y entonces esta partícula de
xenón tiene una carga positiva pero de
una manera muy rápida ya que hay muchos
electrones corriendo alrededor
probablemente no sea éste el mismo
electrón que estamos contando pero de
alguna parte toma un electrón para
obtener una carga neutra pero estás en
lo correcto si piensas que entonces éste
se vuelve unión por una cantidad de
tiempo muy pequeña en fin hagamos el
último en este caso tenemos razón 222
rato con 222 julio el número atómico es
86 y este se va a convertir en
polonio 218 con un número atómico de 84
y de hecho este es un caso muy
interesante el polonio es nombrado así
por el país polonia pues fue justo ahí
donde nació
marie curie y de hecho polonia en los
1800 no era un país independiente era un
territorio controlado por rusia prusia y
austria y bueno realmente querían
hacerle saber a la gente que eran un
solo pueblo así que ellos descubrieron
que cuando el ratón de caía formaba este
elemento y lo nombraron antes de que se
formara su patria antes de que se
formara colonia ya sabes los privilegios
de encontrar un nuevo elemento pero
bueno aquí de cualquier manera
regresemos al problema que pasó aquí
nosotros tenemos una masa atómica en la
cual disminuyó en cuatro okey estamos
disminuyendo en cuatro y nuestro número
atómico disminuyó en dos lo que quiere
decir que estamos emitiendo una
articulada de helio estamos liberando
una partícula de helio que es justo esta
de aquí un núcleo de helio y entonces
éste tiene una masa atómica de 4 y 2
protones lo que quiere decir que estamos
hablando de el decaimiento tipo alfa
decaimiento de crecimiento tipo alfa ok
y de hecho podemos escribir que este
núcleo de helio + 2 el cual no tiene
electrones los obtendrás de una manera
inmediata y pasa lo mismo con el polonia
hasta la próxima